well if it's your dream and you should
follow your heart over the past two
decades Disney and Nickelodeon have
rocket launched young talents into
superstardom with TV shows movies and
record deals a fair few former stars
have made a name for themselves in
cinema after leaving both networks but
some were forgotten that they were ever
on their Victoria Justice is the
Nickelodeon starlet with a long
impressive resume she was first
introduced on zoey 101 as lola martinez
a new student who is an aspiring actress
justise also guest-starred on the second
episode of the Disney Channel series The
Suite Life of Zack and Cody in which she
played a young pageant contestant Cody
Cole Sprouse instantly fell in love with
named Rebecca but we all recognize her
from her role in victorious as Tori Vega
along with her co-star Ariana Grande her
talent helps persuade TV writer and
producer Dan Schneider to then give her
her own musical show she said quotes Dan
found out that I could also sing and
dance as well as act so we thought it
would be really cool to create a show
for me on Nickelodeon called victorious
it's like the stars were aligning and
Victoria was meant to be for stardom
soon after Victoria's hit the air and
this was the blossoming of her showing
us what she could do musically and
acting wise the series even got its own
television movie called I party which
was a crossover episode of the
television series icarly and victorious
oh my god you have no idea your web show
however in May 2012 it was announced
that victorious was cancelled for
unknown reasons miranda cosgrove found
fame at a very young age and attained
her first notable role as summer
Hathaway in 2003
School of Rock the following year she
scored her iconic role as scheming
younger sister Megan Parker on
Nickelodeon's Drake & Josh before
landing the starring role on the
network's iCarly in which she played
carly shay the show is a major success
to the actress who brought in a great
stream of income earning her a spot in
the 2012 Guinness Book of Records as the
world's highest-paid child actress as
for Disney miranda also voiced
era in the crossover episode more follow
mu of lilo and stitch the series we all
love Bailey Madison in goodwitch as
grace Russell and we certainly can never
forget when she played Natalie Portman's
daughter Isabel on brothers but before
that the young actress actually spent
some time on the Disney Channel she
captured the audience's hearts with her
bowl of Maybell Erin's in the 2007
Disney fantasy drama film bridge to
terabithia when she played the younger
sister of the lead male character played
by Josh Hutcherson can't it's a free
country Madison also had a reoccurring
role in the Disney Channel Original
Series Wizards of Waverly Place as
Maxine Russo in which she played the
girl form of max Russo and when she was
only nine years old the talented young
actors played Mary Alice Johansson a
girl who lived with a foster family in
the Nickelodeon original movie Merry
Christmas Drake and Josh we wanted you
guys to have a nice Christmas - the
movie was based on the remarkable sitcom
Drake and Josh we still can't believe
that was 12 years ago Maddie Ziegler is
best known for the reality series Dance
Moms and her memorable appearances in
several SIA music videos but additional
to dancing maddie started her acting
career with guest spots on multiple
shows she appeared on the Disney Channel
series Austin and Ally in the episode
homework and hidden talents in which she
played a character named Shelby who was
a new student at the Austin and Ally
Music Factory now you try
okay delicate and in 2016 she guest
starred in the episode ballet and the
beasts on Nickelodeon's Nicky Ricky
Dicky and Dawn a year later she returned
to the show in the episode keeping up
with the quoi - Ian's
before she was Aria Montgomery on the
ABC mystery thriller series Pretty
Little Liars Lucy Hale spent some time
on both Disney and Nickelodeon she
appeared on a 2006 episode of
Nickelodeon's Drake and Josh in which
she played hazel a girl who went on a
date with Drake to a movie in the
episode theater thug so what's your name
Hey
Oh like the nut she also appeared in the
upperclassmen and gross biology
dissection episode of Ned's Declassified
School Survival Guide as Amy the girl
Moses crush was trying to make jealous
as for Disney Lucy played Miranda Justin
Russo's girlfriend in an episode of
Wizards of Waverly Place and voiced
periwinkle in the 2012 Disney Fairies
film secret of the wings
why didn't you tell me and for those who
don't know Lucy also sings she covered
Demi Lovato's version of let it go in a
duet with Rascal Flatts
for we love Disney that is a long resume
one of the first things stoner did in
showbiz was being hired by the Disney
Channel in 2001 to host a promotional
series called Mike's super short show
it's still kind of amazing she was only
eight years old when she landed this gig
though she held the hosting spot for six
years those of you watching Disney
Channel in the early 2000s also remember
her appearances in the mouse houses
popular preteen shows like The Suite
Life of Zack and Cody and fatso Raven a
Serena collodion stoner also appeared in
Drake and Josh as windy the girl who
annoyed Drake about wanting him to be
her boyfriend I go to the town show
every year just to see you I even have
some of your songs on TV but most
importantly we can never forget when she
provided the voice of isabella
garcia-shapiro in the Disney Channel
animated series Phineas and Ferb and
personally came up with Isabella's
catchphrase and finally in 2008 she
starred in the Disney Channel original
movie Camp Rock and Camp Rock to the
Final Jam as Kaitlyn Gellar in which she
played an aspiring music producer
Hudgens rose to fame portraying
Gabriella Montez in Disney's High School
Musical film series few can forget
Vanessa's epic on screen and off screen
romance with Zac Efron in Disney's all
three parts and she quickly became a
household name she has an amazing voice
perhaps the next music app however
Hudgens wasn't always known as Gabriella
from the high school musical films she
was once known as Lindsay when she guest
starred on an episode of the brothers
Garcia charmed by her larry tries to
keep his cool as he prepares to ask her
out but things don't go as planned
shortly after her high school musical
success
Vanessa appeared in the Drake & Josh
episode little sibling as Becca Drake
Parker's girlfriend Thank You Becca
of course she only had a few scenes but
at least she got to kiss Drake so
there's that we can't mention Vanessa
Hudgens without remembering her High
School Musical co-star Ashley Tisdale
although she had been working in the
industry since the mid-90s Ashley's big
break came when she landed the role of
Maddie Fitzpatrick on The Suite Life of
Zack and Cody in 2005 I wish I could do
something to help can you give me fifty
million dollars but before starring on
The Suite Life of Zack and Cody and in
the high school musical films Tisdale
guest-starred on The Amanda Show
she played Daphne Amanda Bynes number
one fan who gets tan argument with
Penelope taint Bynes
also Amanda's other number one fan it's
you have an Amanda quiz off to see who's
the top fan spoiler it wasn't as Dell
she's right about a year later she was
cast as Sharpay in the hit movie High
School Musical you might also recognize
her voice in the Disney Channel animated
series Phineas and Ferb she played the
voice of Candace Flynn Tisdale has more
than 20 years in the entertainment
industry and she's definitely not
flowing down nails jowls acting career
took off when she won a co-starring role
in the Nickelodeon hit sitcom unfabulous
with Emma Roberts where she played Geena
Fabiano one of the best friends of
Roberts character Addie singer the show
ran for three seasons from 2004 to 2007
Jo is also known for her role as Lucy on
Big Time Rush another Nickelodeon sitcom
and her appearance on iCarly on the
episode I look alike in which he played
the fake carly shay she then continued
to build her teen fanbase by starring on
Disney shows Jo appeared on Wizards of
Waverly Place in the episode movies in
which she portrayed the role of Ruby
Donohue a musical icon who Alex Russo
sneaks behind her brothers back to hang
out with and you might actually remember
this but djal also guest-starred on
Disney's Hannah Montana oh go I have my
pride
Nicolle who played Mesa Mesa on Jonas
started her acting career on
Nickelodeon's unfabulous as a
cheerleader before she started hanging
out with the Joe Broz she appeared on
zoey 101 in which Maria aka the girl
that Quinn Aaron Sanders thought was
trying to steal her boyfriend but was
really just painting a portrait of him
so he could give it to Quinn as a gift
whoops
Nicole was also on iCarly she was that
snooty girl Tasha who told Carly miranda
cosgrove that if Carly were really that
cool of a website she would have read
about it on nevelocity.com
I guess your web shows lame she did
however guest star on Hannah Montana a
few months prior to her iCarly
appearance but that was also before her
Jonas days
I can't believe an actual member Jonas
is helping me with my singing no matter
your age these shows were probably a
major part of your childhood Disney and
Nickelodeon gave us some of our favorite
shows and yes some of our favorite stars
which actresses appearance did you
already know about and which one
surprised you the most let us know in
the comments below don't be shy don't
forget to Like and subscribe and we'll
see you again right here on the things
thanks for watching and bye for now
you